and we begin this morning with the
growing pressure on the Trump
administration for answers about the
deaths of four US Army soldiers in
Nazaire the death of Sergeant David
Johnson and three other soldiers has
congressional leaders asking the
Pentagon for answers about the operation
we share Johnson's funeral is scheduled
for today in Florida and president
Trump's response to how he deals with
grieving military families has touched
off a feud with a Democratic
congresswoman and the media Errol
Barnett is at the White House
Erol good morning good morning a US law
enforcement official confirms to CBS
News that the FBI is now assisting in
the military's investigation of that
deadly ambush in Neesha which killed
sergeant Johnson and his fellow soldiers
but the White House remains tight-lipped
President Trump refused to answer a
pointed question over his role even as
new information on the US operation in
which four soldiers were killed came to
light the body of Sergeant Lee David
Johnson was found nearly a mile away
from the ambush site Pentagon officials
say a locator beacon was tracked for
several hours fueling hopes he was alive
but the biggest mystery is why the
patrol had not expected enemy contact in
a part of New Year where this UN map
shows 46 attacks took place over the
last 20 months
a day after Senator John McCain said it
may be necessary to issue a subpoena to
the Pentagon the Secretary of Defense
was summoned to the Capitol General
James maddest Talde Senator McCain and
Senator Lindsey Graham and back-to-back
briefings that the war on terrorism is
shifting to Africa also president
Trump's impromptu remarks in a Tuesday
condolence call to a grieving widow of
one of the soldiers killed in the attack
ignited a firestorm
why was he left alone was he still alive
Florida congresswoman Frederica Wilson
criticized the president for telling
sergeant Johnson's Widow quote he knew
what he signed up for you don't call up
a young young woman a grieving mother of
two who is with child and say your
husband know your guy knew when he
signed up what he was getting himself
into but in an interview sent to a
Sunday the president doubles down and
the call was a very nice call now
President Trump earlier in the week
claimed that he had contacted virtually
every gold star family that had lost a
military service member during his time
in office but a report in a capitol hill
newspaper contradicts that claim and
shows senior White House aides did not
even have an up-to-date list of
Americans killed in action Alex
Errol Barnett at the White House thinks
Errol